so
good afternoon um thank you very much
you know
and uh honored to be uh being president
of this meeting
musk and i want to really thank brett
and
uh parade funkers all of them
for giving an opportunity to be being
there
so i just want to take a little story we
are a startup
in 96 97 we are a startup company
only thing we need to have some focus
what do we want so i always think that
no country no company
is my competitors but i always believe
that infectious diseases are competitors
and my goal was to identify niche
that we should work on neglected
diseases why neglected diseases
neglected diseases turn out to be mostly
focused in the developing world and it
turned out to be
most of the neglected disease is you
becomes mandatory
so if you work on network you're also
working an abandonment
that's how we focus as a game plan right
from the
beginning as a company and then
you know vaccine is everybody asked me
can you give me a vaccine in one year
six months eight months
just gives you a slight you know even
when the regulatory system was so weak
in the earlier part
only it took seven years at that time
reason took nine years when there was
regulatory was not that strong
and today for a rotavirus vaccine it
took us 14 years for us to
bring the vaccine dota various banks so
please understand
that vaccine is a long term drop not a
short term drop
not like pharma industry faction is
totally a different game
and then you know the vaccine field is a
high risk and
irony failures are very high look at
malaria and hiv
the best of the mind has been
considerate in hiv and malaria
and so much of funding has gone but
nothing has been made a success
and so very risky and also this is going
to the child to the others
and healthy people so adverse reaction
has become very important
you know in adverse reaction a cancer
patient not be possible to detect much
but in a healthy individuals a smaller
survivors reaction also can be a
dangerous
and the new technologies you need to see
like mrna vaccine
you need to see how this adversation can
be an impact in the long run we don't
know yet
and also vaccine is not like a
biosimilar in pharma
lot of ethical issues are there when a
healthy baby
gets some info some other problem then
ethical issues
comes into the picture and also this is
very important
it's a public health and a global public
health has become an important
not like a cancer where cancer patients
are localized
and cardiology localized but public
health means to the community based firm
cost matters because now is going to the
public health program
cost definitely matters because it's
going to entire population
when you go to entire population cost
becomes an important factor
and government plays a major role in uh
you know handling the
action field that's why the government
is a very important partner in all this
program
and our thing is see many people think
india
is a copycat country you know people
think it's like pharma company
generic country we are not a generic
country the new generation
entrepreneurs like me are changing the
game plan
in the country at least we are the
rotavak we are the largest manufacturers
in the world
at least we have beaten even gsk in
terms of capacity
i bought tcv was the toughest type of
conjugate vaccine we made in the world
and at least we are better than gsk mark
in terms of our pfizer
first time to bring the wax into the
grow chicken ghonia we're the first
company
zika were the first company to file a
global pattern in nts new vaccine brand
new
action funded by welcome trust we got
usfdi india approved
and we had then phase one uh just
completed phase one
in baltimore that speaks that we are not
anymore a generic maxim company
we are focused a lot of innovation
innovation and that are
global public health problems and i
think rotavak
we've changed the game because many wax
in rota is a basically 1.5 to 2 mm
we brought first time in the world at
just a five drop concept
and we are the first one to change the
delivery system so that even another
i mean unknown uneducated person can
dismiss this vaccine
by having a five drops so we brought it
changes and we are the first one to do
the 25 000
newborn babies clinical trial efficacy
trial first time in this country
or even in the developing world first
company to do an efficacy trial with a
25 000
uh babies in the world thanks to this
could be possible
because of bill and melinda gates
foundation they gave us 200 million
dollars
indirect grants to various institutes
for all the clinical trial
uh both phase two and phase three
efficacy trial funded by them
and i want to thank for that so this
made a prime minister honorable prime
minister on this vaccine
now according to national immigration
program now we are supplying to more
than 120 countries
globally and we have now got a landsat
publication
why i'm saying this we are not just a
manufacturing company we are also very
research oriented companies
the second one we look at type 5 is
mostly neglected
because u.s and europe doesn't have
typhoid problems so many multinational
never worked on typhoid so we said we
should do
who is the kids of typhoid problem in
the developing world the newborn baby
three six months nine months baby who
doesn't get a good water
good hygienic food they get infected and
they get salmonella problem
and salmon will also become a
multi-regression i said we should do
something to the for children of this
developing world and we made this type
of conjugate vaccine
first time in the world and that the
first probably first innovation
from india now these kind of action can
be given from six months onwards
the existing type of vaccine is can be
given about two years
not less than two years and also the
efficacy is only 60 percent
now that's a game we played and we
brought a type of conjugate vaccine
and thanks to gate foundation they get
20 million dollars grant to andrew
pollard
in oxford and we have done the first
human challenge studies
now people talking about human challenge
studies for co-weight and all that
and we are the first one from the
developing world to do the human
challenge studies
and then we publish in landsat for the
publication
and then new york times has covered this
our first small company from hyderabad
has made it to happen a global product
and made it a vaccine efficacy of 87
percent
in the human challenge studies 87
percent of human challenge studies
is a very significant factor and world
bank or
doublehc said this is one of the
breakthrough vaccine
for typhoid and nature medicine
in 2018 said that this is one of the
treatment that made headline in 2018 in
the world globally
or tybott tcv was mentioned by the
nature of medicine
and i think you know we've got an
extremely good experience in critical
trials
we're doing more than uh uh 80 countries
i'm sorry for
12 countries we're doing a clinical
trial and we've done 600 000 babies
we're done
trial and more than 80 clinical trials
that shows
that we are very strong in clinical
trial we discussed
12 billion doses of vaccine in more than
120 countries
and uh we also patent worldwide we will
be a strong believer of intellectual
property
we have more than 427 patterns uh
globally covering
on various issues our partners are
global
and i'll leave it there but uh i'm
thanks to the
gate foundation welcome to us norway
government government of india
and we got a great grant from the gate
foundation to
university of maryland and uh oxford
and sippy gave recently for chicken muni
vaccine
14.1 million dollars to ibi
partnership program for chicken gurney
so we're thankful
for coming to the committed action and
we
decided that we don't want to be a
contract manufacturer
under any circumstances the reason why
i'm saying is
we have two options either we
manufacture our sun
or be a partner with somebody else and
manufacture
but that we looked at as a company in
the long run how do we position
ourselves
as a company in a copy to action do we
want to be a contract manufacturer
or do we partner with academic
institutes in u.s
so that we have patent rights license
from them
and then we take on further the program
so that is how we focus on the period
actually so you look at the provider
action strategy
your 170 vaccines many r d companies
have everybody said
started doing now i have a power to
actually have power to action
so your number of phase one seven
vaccine number of action in phase two
twelve
and the number of phase three are
probably seven
although only three is the leading right
now three vaccines only the leading
and approved although russia china
claims they are approved
but we still don't know yet but
otherwise zero
so many rna companies may develop of
action the what is shortage globally
is a manufacturing facility so out of
these 170 companies
may not survive because they cannot
scale it up to the manufacturing
facilities
so that it may die but the good concept
good r d
uh good ideas comes out but what reaches
the field is going to be very limited
and then what we do we did is we took a
partnership
okay the reason is we strong believer of
a public private partnership
because the company cannot do everything
on our own
yes we can do it but it's a very long
draw and
more human resources and also building
the core strength of each field
is going to be complicated for us he
said let's partner with icmr
one of the vaccine making inactivated
sorry um so the why we partner with icmr
because national institute of virology
pune is one of the
top institute like a cdc of india
so we said let's partner with them we
both one plus one can be 11
in terms of knowledge that's we've
partnered we have fortnite thomas
jefferson with the us
and the philadelphia and we also
partnered with you a universe of
wisconsin
so icmr we partnered strategically a
public pride partnership
so that they can help us on various
things so look at the platform
technology
very simple in this case there are two
weekend
you know weekend vaccine which uh
codagenics is working in u.s
is optimizing codon so that it's not an
infectious particle
but it can create like a live virus type
of immune responses
but still in rnd stages another one is
just inactivated
you just you see the dna you have rna
same rna
is inactivated another one codon is
changed
that's all the differences in that this
is the live world when live
covered virus uh red color
so you kill them with a chemical like a
beer upgrade appropriate lacto
and kill them and then you have
presenting abc presentation cell
and then you have t cell and b cell
responses in the human body
our strategy was to have more th1
responses
that's one of the reason we choose a
different game
where chinese have done the inactivated
vaccine without
with only pure alum and we know that the
problem with the alum is
it will be more of a th2 response not
the th1 responses
so we want to have a th1 response which
are very critical
for the long-term immunity point of view
so we choose that
and what we did is we licensed one of
the attribute
from the uh bureau wax from the u.s
company small
startup company from kansas we i saw we
have uh licensed
klr7 and 8 agonist
and this agonist is attached to the alum
attached to the alum and then we put it
to the game
so what is needed for this vaccine you
need a psn3 containment
at least i'm happy to say that we are
the only one in the world
vsl3 production facility psl3 labs
always everywhere is there in the world
but bsl-3 production facility
we are the first one in the world now
china is tribally trying to build
they have only bsl-2 right now they are
going to build i believe they are
building on bsl-3 production basically
or we are the first one in the world to
have two psl3 production facility
uh first time in the world we created
that that came in handy for us
to make this live virus to multiply in
this platform
and then produce inactivated max so
we have extremely good knowledge on zero
cell manufacturing platform
because this is originally funded by
gate foundation
for the rotter verification so that
platform
now expanded to rabies jai chikungunya
zika
so many other nine waxes probably we are
the only company in the world
having a viral cell culture platform
with more than nine to ten batches
produced in uracil platform including
polio injectable polio acts
so i think we are taking a leadership
role in the middleself culture platform
and we are scaling up very well and
moving in the direction
in this partnership we made a gmp
production because in india
you need unless you have gmp product you
can't do the
even talks college studies in india so
that is required three batches we made
and now it's going on through trial and
also we did the live viral challenge
studies
monkeys enhancers in pune niv pony
the data has been submitted for
publication so i can't disclose more on
that right now
thank you and then what is the advantage
of covax
so it leaves the slc production facility
u.s and europe cannot manufacture this
faction
because that is why because they wrote a
psl3 they can't make a live action
because of their chosen alternative
strategies like mrna vaccine
and uh chipanya i don't know whereas
like the best vaccine
and is a what i believe is the
inactivated reaction
safe and time tested you look at rabies
action injectable polio action
and a lot of other axes are just purely
inactivated reactions
it's the same and is a you can give it
from child to pregnant ladies
like a vector-based action like
chimpanzee you can't give it to child
and pregnant ladies and some cancer
patients also
you cannot do that you know i don't know
biased vector-based waxes
the nice thing about this one you can
incorporate any adjuvant you want to
introduce for a senior citizens suppose
somebody was at 85 years old
they don't respond the vaccine you can
add some new other adjoint
that is the reason why we chose taylor
seven and eight
as an adjuvant added to this one to
strategize
that it can produce a ph one response
and also long-term immunity
and uh the same the safest strategy the
product this is the safest strategy in
the world
the disadvantage will be the capacity
and the cost
cost will be little higher definitely
higher because it's a producing live
action and then inactivating we lose
quite a bit of
live virus particles while inactivation
in the purification is there
the second platform is thomas jefferson
the license is uh
is the rabies platform so again it's a
base vector based vaccine
but then after vector based vaccine
produced we make them again inactivated
we have option to go as a rabies vector
as a live action
or an activated maxim so we choose
inactivation strategy
because we want safety factors into the
gate
so we chose that method it's a basically
a thymeric protein hymeric reaction
wave is glycoprotein attached with a
spike protein we are not as
it's a s1 here s1 gene is attached to
that
s1 has got rbd also together in that
so s1 combined with the radius vector
blast diaphragm
so we made again five batches production
jv production
right now the p clinically going on so
we are also introducing an adjuvant here
a lipid-based adjuvant and so that we
can have dose pairing capacity
and also high immunogenicity which can
tilt to
ph 1 responses in the humans so that's a
focus we are doing right now on the
second floor the third platform
uh with the university of wisconsin so
here's the nasal base reaction
so why nasal mass reaction i'll explain
to the next slide
but but this is a basically a flu
strategy
so while you look at here you have a
replicating viral vector
non-replicating variable vector ours is
a non-replicating director
once you give the flu vaccine to your
body it can only multiply one time after
that it cannot multiply
it dies it needs a host particular zero
cells
it requires to multiply but if you put
it outside the very cells
it doesn't multiply so that is why it's
called non-replicating viral vector
and it's a similar concept what i've
shown you earlier the even response of
the same
so what is the challenge for us in the
world but let's look at the india
i don't want to talk globally but look
at uh
for indian coverage of action problem if
the every vaccine is going to be given
two doses
output vaccine is also two dozen and
chopin's adenoids are true dose vaccine
and mrna vaccine is also true dorsal
action and you look at insulins mean
for indian population 1.3 billion
population
two doses is going to be required 2.6
billion doses for india itself
and what you needed 2.6 billion syringes
are needed
you globe seven billion population with
the two doses 14 billion population
that means 14 billion syringes and
needles
where do we get that syringes and
needles and also
look at the impact of the environmental
pollution that they can create
to the world and a number of syringes
that can go
and a cold chain you look at a uh 2.6
billion syringes a needle
2.6 billion doses that has to be
dispersed in cold chain
and it's going to break down a
particular developing world you will
develop nation
even us already us is facing mrna
vaccine
is going to be minus 96 temperature so
how do you go to dispense minus 20 96
temperature
is going to be an issue of delivery
system to the field
and so the delivery of injection 25
million in india
your children's vaccination is very easy
your 25 million children
your three doses vaccine 75 million
syringes
needle easy to do it but you come to 2.6
billion syringes
a needle is going to be a herculean task
and also
um it's a pro the problem is you want to
increase the head immunity
head immunity vaccination is only
strategy but then how do you increase it
so i think we are looking at an
alternative strategy nasal drop
is one of the strategies which will
survive in a global point of view
and we are working very aggressively on
nasal drought vaccine
which can give you one dose of action
and another delivery
that can be delivered even after the
field situations
where they it can reach the rural area
and that's our focus right now
and i think i want to thank for murk
giving me this opportunity
and particularly for our uh for giving
me opportunity for this
video thank you very much
you